another big development on friday the
house passed the democrats so-called
inflation reduction act targeting
billions of dollars for health climate
and for trimming the federal deficit now
the bill heads to president biden's
death to become law cbs news senior
white house and political correspondent
ed o'keefe is traveling with the
president who's vacationing on kiawah
island south carolina ed good morning
michelle good morning the inflation
reduction act as you mentioned
includes about 370 billion dollars to
fight climate change the largest ever
investment by the federal government to
do so there's also new language now that
makes it
impossible to raise insurance premiums
and about 13 million americans who rely
on the affordable care act and allows
medicare to negotiate drug prices for
the first time it's all paid for with a
new minimum tax on some billion dollar
corporations that currently pay almost
nothing to the u.s government and
there's new funding for tens of
thousands of new irs agents to go after
big time tax cheats as you mentioned the
president plans to sign this next week
formally real quick but they're going to
hold a bigger event after labor day with
democrats to celebrate the passage of
this bill and launch the midterm
campaign season we're going to be
talking about passage of this bill which
took more than a year to negotiate among
democrats plus passage of other
legislation this summer including the
new gun control and mental health bill
and other bipartisan legislation to help
veterans and boost the semiconductor
industry all of it designed to suggest
to voters that two years of democratic
control of washington should be rewarded
with at least two more whether or not
that works of course remains to be seen
and to that point this was a signature
piece of president biden's agenda but
the focus of the nation seems to be on
this this search this fbi search of the
former president's home so how is the
white house reacting to that
they're reacting by not reacting we ask
them you know what does the president
make of this were you aware of the raid
in advance they insisted the justice
department did not give the white house
a heads up the president had no idea and
learned about it with the rest of us
that's in keeping with a policy that's
been in place since he took office and
by keeping him essentially out of the
public view this week with a
coincidentally timed vacation
politically they believe look when he
lies low like this and the former
president is out there in the news you
know making waves the way he does
that works it worked two summers ago
when then candidate biden was
essentially forced to campaign from his
basement in delaware and the former
president was out there doing things and
they believe now in essence that while
he's been lying low over the last few
weeks due to kovid now due to his
vacation you will see him out there in
public in the coming weeks making the
case for democrats to hold on to control
of congress
ed what if any other political
ramifications do you see coming from the
news about the former president
well look it's been a great political
week for the former president himself
because it's led to
essentially the republican party
rallying around him it's helped with his
fundraising it's solidified or
reiterated his position at the top of
the party and some primary results this
week and next week also reinforce that
for the broader republican party being
so closely associated with a former
president that's now under investigation
in this way certainly runs the political
risk of causing some of these people to
lose their jobs in november especially
those perhaps in closer races or in
states where donald trump isn't as
popular if you're a conservative
republican from a deep red district
you'll stand by him as much as you need
to but for those that are in tougher
races watch to see how much distance
they might put between themselves and
him just by virtue of the fact that they
don't know we don't know where this
criminal investigation is headed
last night in pennsylvania uh senate
candidate john fetterman returned
to the campaign trail for the first time
since his health scare um that there's
the potential for pennsylvania to flip
in the senate our demo we're 86 or 87
days away from the midterms right now
depending on how you count are democrats
feeling more or less optimistic right
now
they're feeling more optimistic at least
in holding on to the senate because they
see their candidates
in polling in these battleground states
doing better than they might have
anticipated john fetterman is one good
example of that pennsylvania is a state
that democrats could pick up they see
their candidates doing okay in places
like ohio arizona and georgia as well
against perhaps weaker than expected or
less aggressive republican candidates
i'd only add this it's august many
americans are just getting back to
school they're still on vacation they're
not thinking about electoral politics
the way we do let's check the numbers
again after labor day into that stretch
through november either way this much is
probably certain guys we live in a 50 50
country most of these results are going
to be around 50 50. we're looking at a
lot of close races across the country
this year
and as we started talking about ed that
string of successes on the legislative
side certainly democrats had to at least
take a little bit of positive
reinforcement from ed thank you